[Música]
hola muy buenas tardes muchas gracias
por venir bueno yo soy alfred soy
astrofísico divulgador de la astrofísica
de canarias y mi misión es un poco
trasladar a la sociedad los
conocimientos en astronomía para ello
utilizó cualquier método de subirme a un
teatro con unas marionetas exposiciones
que es el que voy a tratar de contarles
hoy
y yo espero que me acompañen en este
breve paseo por el cosmos que está
basado en una exposición que se titula
100 lunas cuadradas con una exposición a
un proyecto divulgativo que está
itinerando por todas las islas canarias
también ha estado en el instituto
cervantes de japón en tokio y en el
parlamento europeo recientemente en
bruselas y bueno hasta los políticos los
hemos convencido un poco de que puede
ser interesante
la
la charla va a ir un poco en este
sentido voy a apoyarme mucho en las
imágenes para tratar de trasladarle los
conocimientos que hemos ido adquiriendo
en astronomía y un poco pues que les
sirva de inspiración también el universo
aquí la primera clave es entender por
qué llamamos a esta exposición 100 lunas
cuadradas pues bien si se fijan aquí
tenemos una imagen de la luna a color
son colores forzados pero colores reales
de la luna y está enmarcada con un fondo
de estrella si se fijan bien podemos
colocar diez lunas por diez lunas en
este marco en este trozo de cielo que
estamos viendo todas las imágenes de la
exposición que vamos a mostrar tienen
exactamente este mismo pedazo de cielo
es decir es un cuadradito en el cielo de
distintos objetos y esos objetos nos van
a ayudar a contar astrofísica en este
caso por ejemplo en la imagen que
estamos tomando de fondo pueden ver aquí
a la derecha como el cuadradito rojo
representaría en el cielo en este mapa
estelar el trocito de cielo que estamos
viendo y en él estamos sobreponiendo
estamos muy cerca de la del disco de la
vía láctea y estamos pillando
200.000 estrellas aquí junto con la luna
tenemos 200.000 estrellas de nuestra
galaxia que están relativamente cerca
pues bien durante varios años un
satélite llamado kepler estuvo
observando cada cinco minutos obteniendo
una imagen y viendo cuando alguna de
esas estrellas disminuye un poquitito su
brillo para determinar si esos si esas
estrellas podrían tener planetas
alrededor
kepler ha conseguido descubrir miles de
planetas hasta hace poco más de dos
décadas desconocíamos que existiesen
planetas en torno a otras estrellas sin
embargo hoy en día sabemos que la
mayoría de las estrellas tienen planetas
incluso sistemas planetarios alrededor
aquí de estas estrellas que estamos
mostrando hay alrededor de las 200.000
hay alrededor de un centenar que tiene
un planeta girando alrededor estas que
he señalado son sistemas planetarios
tienen dos o más planetas y en
particular aquí esta estrellita que
debería estar en medio de ese circulito
tiene cinco planetas girando alrededor
así que hoy en día ya somos capaces de
localizar planetas en torno a otras
estrellas
tremenda
pues bien ya entendemos de qué va la
exposición y un primer logro de la
astrofísica actual de las últimas
décadas es que ya sabemos que existen
planetas hemos verificado que existen
planetas en torno a casi todas las
estrellas y el siguiente paso que
queríamos mostrarle es que las estrellas
nacen viven y mueren todas las estrellas
los pocos miles que podemos ver a simple
vista y los trillones de estrellas que
existen en el universo todas ellas nacen
viven y mueren actualmente conocemos
esos procesos bastante bien y todas
ellas nacen en grandes nubes de gas
formados por hidrógeno y helio son los
elementos más abundantes con diferencia
en el universo y que eran los únicos que
existían en el inicio en el origen del
universo pues bien van creando nubes que
se van a ir dividiendo en pequeños
grupos que por efecto de la gravedad se
van a ir colapsando y va a ir aumentando
la presión y la temperatura en su
interior cuando esos grumos llegan a
alcanzar temperaturas de millones 10 15
50 millones de grados en su interior los
átomos de hidrógeno comienzan a ser
capaces de unirse entre sí y dan lugar a
nuevos átomos
que serán de helio produciendo energía
entonces se comienzan a producir las
reacciones de fusión nuclear y se forman
las estrellas las estrellas son sistemas
son esferas de materia que están en
equilibrio entre dos fuerzas por un lado
la fuerza de la gravedad que trata de
aplastarla y la calienta y por otro lado
la fuerza de radiación desde esa fuente
de energía que trata de expandirla pues
muy bien aquí estamos este es en la zona
central cerca del centro de la vía
láctea en la que estamos mirando estas
son las regiones que estamos observando
en esta imagen la luna es
aproximadamente del tamaño de este
círculo para que sean una idea del
tamaño que estamos observando en el
cielo pero bueno todas estas imágenes
están tomadas con una cámara y un
telescopio que para poderlo ver a simple
vista así necesitaríamos una visión en
torno a mil millones de veces más
potente que nuestros ojos así que los
humanos somos muy hábiles buscando
prótesis para poder conseguir ver él
llegará a lugares más lejanos y con
mayor resolución de estas nubes van a
nacer aquí podemos ver las pléyades
todos seguramente todos habrán visto
alguna vez las pléyades cerca de la
constelación de tauro
aquí tenemos orión pues bien vemos un
grupito de estrellas que aquí están
señaladas y vemos que existen muchas
estrellas de distintos brillos cuando
las estrellas nacen en las nebulosas
pueden ser de muy diversos tamaños las
más brillantes en este caso las
estrellas que podemos ver a simple vista
por la noche tienen en torno a 8 veces
la masa del sol y por lo tanto van a
brillar mil veces más que el sol y por
eso las podemos ver tan lejos en este
caso este grupo está a 440 años luz de
distancia
pero no solo existen esas estrellas
existen muchas más más de mil estrellas
en el caso de las pléyades y
paulatinamente las más pequeñas son más
débiles brillan menos y viven mucho más
tiempo porque saben repartir mucho más
la energía que disponen a lo largo del
tiempo y de hecho hay unas estrellas en
el límite de lo que tenemos entre
estrellas y planetas que son las enanas
blancas las enanas blancas se
descubrieron por primera vez desde el
observatorio del teide en 1995 en este
cúmulo en particular la enana blanca que
se descubrió se llamó teide 1 y es una
enana marrón situada en esta posición
hoy en día sabemos que más del 25 por
ciento de las estrellas del universo son
enanas marrones pero son tan débiles que
cuesta mucho detectarlas esto es otra
región del cielo es la el corazón del
escorpión y aquí vemos varias nebulosas
de muchos colores una zona preciosa muy
cromática en la que vemos las nebulosas
esas nubes de las que dan lugar
normalmente a las estrellas las hay
rojas que están siendo cargadas de
energía por la estrella central y
rebotando esos átomos de hidrógeno la
energía pero también las haya azules
amarilla que lo que están haciendo es
reflejar la luz de la estrella en torno
a la cual se encuentran o hay nebulosas
más oscuras que lo que están haciendo
son son muy opacas y no dejan pasar la
luz también tenemos cuando estos son las
cinco estrellas que podríamos ver a
simple vista a nosotros y también
tenemos unos objetos muy peculiares que
son los cúmulos globulares
no todas las estrellas son jóvenes como
en el caso de las pléyades recién
nacidas hay estrellas que nacieron junto
con la formación de la vía láctea como
es el caso de los cúmulos globulares y
estas estrellas tienen más de 12 mil
millones de años este tipo de estrellas
este cúmulo está aquí y está
relativamente cerca a unos 77 mil años
luz de distancia aquí tenemos otro
cúmulo bastante más lejos en torno a
unos 20 a 25 y bueno estos objetos tan
antiguos nos ayudan a entender cómo se
forman y cómo evolucionan las galaxias
pero las estrellas nacen viven y mueren
en particular nuestra estrella el sol ha
vivido durante 5 mil millones de años no
existido desde el principio del universo
sino arrancó dos terceras partes después
del origen del universo y todavía va a
vivir cinco mil millones de años más
pero cuando muera lo va a ser como una
nebulosa planetaria
así es como mueren las estrellas
pequeñas corrientes como el sol e
incluso estrellas hasta ocho o nueve
veces mayores que el sol van a explotar
como una nebulosa planetaria visto un
poquitito más en grande que tenemos la
nebulosa dembélé es una de las mayores
que tenemos en el cielo está a
aproximadamente unos 1250 años luz de
distancia y tiene como un año luz de
diámetro
cuando la estrella se le acaba el
combustible digamos el hidrógeno y el
helio trata de quemar elementos más
pesados convierte el helio en carbono el
nitrógeno en oxígeno
es decir todos los átomos que nos
componen nosotros somos un 90% átomos de
carbono nitrógeno oxígeno que no
existían en el origen del universo esos
elementos se han formado en el interior
de las estrellas y han pasado al medio
interestelar tras su muerte luego los
restos de esas estrellas vuelven a
formar nebulosas y vuelven a formar
nuevas estrellas y en torno a esas
estrellas aparecen los planetas y en un
planeta como el nuestro hemos surgido a
nosotros así que los átomos que nos
componen estuvieron en un momento dado
en el interior de las estrellas por eso
solemos decir que somos polvo de
estrellas y una imagen un poquito más
detallada y en el centro de la estrella
va a quedar tan solo el núcleo de la
estrella que es una enana blanca
si seguimos pero bueno hay estrellas que
saben morir con clases una aquí tenemos
un remanente de supernova las estrellas
que tienen diez veinte treinta veces el
tamaño del sol no explotan suavemente no
no se expanden sino que provocan una
explosión tan grande que brillan más que
todas las estrellas cien mil millones de
estrellas que tiene la galaxia donde
están durante una o dos semanas y luego
se van apagando y lanzan al medio
interestelar toda esta materia para que
se hagan una idea de lo grande que es
este objeto voy a colocar el número de
lunas que harían falta para cubrirlo en
el cielo cuando salgan por la noche
miren la luna y digan guau harían falta
36 lunas para ocupar el espacio en el
cielo que estoy viendo de este remanente
de supernova realmente este remanente de
supernova está mucho más lejos que la
anterior régulos a planet área y aún así
es capaz de abarcar realmente unos 200
años luz de diámetro y se sigue
expandiendo a 100 kilómetros por segundo
es algo
sorprendente cuando las estrellas
grandes mueren como supernovas dejan en
su centro una estrella de neutrones o un
agujero negro en este caso dejo una
estrella de neutrones que es curioso no
no se encuentra en el centro que es lo
normal sino que se encuentra escapando a
toda velocidad del centro y también
hemos encontrado una estrella gigante
azul de 8 veces el tamaño del sol que va
en sentido opuesto suponemos que esta
estrella antes de morir formar un
sistema binario estaba girando una en
torno a la otra y en el momento de su
muerte de la explosión se perdió ese
equilibrio y ambas salieron disparadas
tal como estamos viendo aquí pues bien
también en estas explosiones se forman
muchos de los elementos químicos más
pesados en la tabla periódica por
ejemplo el oro de un anillo se forman en
procesos muy energéticos como estos así
que es mucho más romántico ahora
entregar un anillo a cualquiera diciendo
mira esto es polvo de una supernova es
como mucho más así que más inspiración
para ustedes
pues bien las estrellas ya hemos visto
que nacen viven y mueren y todas las de
todos los objetos que hemos visto hasta
ahora estaban dentro de nuestra galaxia
aproximadamente en nuestro plano del
disco galáctico y ahora nos vamos a
salir vamos a irnos a otra galaxia esta
es la galaxia de andrómeda también es
gigantesca esta galaxia
aquí para quien sepa situarse en el
suelo en el cielo tenemos a casiopea
pues bueno un poquito por detrás hacia
andrómeda este es el trocito de cielo
que estamos viendo esta galaxia tiene
500.000 millones de estrellas es un poco
mayor que la vía láctea aunque junto con
la galaxia del triángulo las tres forman
la el grupo local las tres galaxias
grandes espirales y luego hay en torno a
60 galaxias más pequeñas que son
galaxias satélites y en conjunto
conforman el grupo local bueno andrómeda
lo que yo quería contarles andrómeda es
que se encuentra a dos millones y medio
de años luz de distancia está lejos no
es el objeto más distante que podemos
ver a simple vista a simple vista en un
cielo muy oscuro sin luna somos capaces
de ver esta estrellita esta otra de aquí
y el núcleo de esta galaxia imagínense
que hay un puente que hay algo muy
particular en la astronomía y es que
estamos limitado a la velocidad de la
luz entonces imagínense que hay un
extraterrestre que está mirándonos hacia
la tierra y pensaremos bueno y nos podrá
ver ahora a nosotros aquí no
estará viendo a luz y un homínido
evolucionar en sudáfrica hace dos
millones y medio de años igual que
nosotros estamos recibiendo los fotones
de esa galaxia que partieron hace dos
millones y medio de años mirar más lejos
en el universo es mirar más atrás en el
tiempo y veremos algún ejemplo más aquí
solo para que se haga una idea este son
el diámetro de la galaxia sería
aproximadamente siete lunas llenas
alineadas
aquí tenemos el tamaño de esta galaxia y
por definirlo mejor lo que serían esas
galaxias satélites que hay alrededor y
bueno todas todas esas galaxias con las
satélites la nuestra con nuestros
satélites y las del triángulo formamos
un grupo de galaxias que denominamos el
grupo local el siguiente grupo más
cercano a nosotros sería el que viene en
la siguiente imagen
aquí estamos viendo la galaxia de 81 m
82 y varias galaxias voy a señalar la
para que vean cómo es el siguiente grupo
más cercano a nosotros no están muy
lejos están a 12 millones de años luz de
distancia y estas son las galaxias que
están ligadas gravitacionalmente hay
algunas más galaxias por aquí detrás
estamos viendo otras aquí debajo pero la
que a mí más me llama la atención son
estas dos pequeñas galaxias que hay aquí
que ha ampliado en la imagen grande
estas dos de aquí los fotones de salud
de esas galaxias partieron hace 200
millones de años 200 millones de años
significa que los fotones partieron
entre el triásico y el jurásico cuando
los dinosaurios estaban todavía reinando
sobre el planeta y de los mamíferos no
había absolutamente nada y ahora es
cuando estamos recibiendo la luz de esas
galaxias y ya siguiendo con este modelo
de irnos alejando poco a poco vamos a
terminar con el grupo de galaxias del
cúmulo de virgo en el cúmulo de virgo
podemos ver muchas galaxias de gran
formato
eso significa galaxias espirales
barradas elípticas por ejemplo han oído
recientemente algo de m87 es donde se
encuentra ese agujero negro esa imagen
de agujero negro que nos han mostrado en
los medios de comunicación
seguramente no sabrían localizarla en el
cielo pues bien es en el centro de esta
galaxia donde se encuentra ese agujero
negro y estas galaxias en conjunto se
encuentran entre 54 y 65 millones de
años luz de distancia eso significa que
más o menos la luz partido de esas
galaxias cuando se extinguieron los
dinosaurios aproximadamente tenemos
algunas galaxias más ésta es la cadena
de markarián y tenemos por aquí
muchísimas galaxias más de hecho en esta
imagen con todas las galaxias que
estamos viendo y éstos trocitos
pequeñitos del cielo donde estamos
observando no estamos yendo más allá del
1% del tamaño del universo el universo
tiene 13 mil 800 millones de años por lo
tanto un radio equivalente y lo que
estamos viendo aquí es una pequeña
representación
de lo que es el universo para acabar y
tratar de inspirarles con las últimas un
pequeño resumen me gustaría que tuviesen
en cuenta lo que hemos visto que existen
exoplanetas en torno a casi todos los
planetas casi todas las estrellas en el
universo que todas las estrellas nacen
viven y mueren que somos literalmente
polvo de estrellas no existía sino
hidrógeno y helio al principio del
universo sin embargo nosotros estamos
compuestos de carbono nitrógeno oxígeno
azufre y hierro y sin embargo todos esos
elementos se tuvieron que producir en
procesos astronómicos en el interior de
las estrellas o en estas grandes
explosiones y que mirar más lejos es
mirar más atrás en el tiempo es decir
cuando estamos mirando galaxias cada vez
más lejanas
estamos mirando más atrás en el tiempo y
ya para acabar el universo tiene 13 mil
800 millones de años tiene más de 200
mil millones de galaxias cada galaxia
tiene cientos de miles de millones de
estrellas y probablemente hay más
planetas que
en el universo así que bueno espero que
les haya servido de inspiración
[Aplausos]
[Música]